here in this video today we shall
discuss about two gigantic monsters that
have quite a lot in common with each
other and both of them are associated
with godzilla even though one is a kaiju
of touhou origin the other is a new
titan in the monster verse so if both
these two share so much in common why
aren't they the same or if they are why
were the names changed so now we will
get into their origins their appearance
abilities and all that jazz so let's get
down to business
the origins of mandar amanda was a sea
dragon who served as the protector of mu
and undersea realm it is unclear as to
how amanda got to be his defender or how
long he has been doing so but amanda
fought the underwater ship called
gotengo by wrapping his body around the
ship and attempting to smash it manta is
one of the creatures kept on monster
island an island located in the osagawa
islands towards the end of the 20th
century in destroy all monsters and
manners origins are unknown in godzilla
final wars and a singular point
the origins of tiamat in mesopotamian
myths tmr was a primordial water goddess
with a dragon-like form symbolizing the
chaos of primordial creation tiamat like
the other titans super species and the
most of us have lived for millions of
years before going into slumber for
unexplained reasons tiamat fought and
killed a titanoscope before when she
entered his lair centuries ago monarch
discovered tiamat near stone mountain
georgia and created outpost 53 around
her then tiamat breaks free and begins
hunting with a new pack after ghidorah
summons all the titans
now let's see the body design of mandar
manda's original show appearance the
show diamanta had four legs many horns
on the head all the way down to the tail
and two barbs emerging from the face
like an eastern dragon mandar appears in
a different form and destroy all
monsters than its last appearance he
lacks feathers feelers horns or a beard
giving him a snake-like look for a more
protagonistic approach its eyes are
bright blue in color and have more round
pupils in final wars he looks similar to
the eastern dragon but in singular point
it looked more like a serpentine
creature than a dragon with sharp scales
bobs and two pins are like four limbs
now the body design of tiamat tiamat is
a giant serpentine creature with
brilliant purple scales and a light blue
color scheme these scales are serrated
in half knife-like appearance her skull
is draconic with two bubbles sprouting
from it and with yellow eyes it has two
wing-like fins extending from near the
skull tiamat is a fiercely territorial
titan who will fight other titans for
supremacy tiamat was visibly terrified
after being defeated by godzilla
following a fierce battle and she
surrendered to the alpha titan to avoid
being killed
now let's see the size of mandar and
timon the size of manda varies in its
three appearances in the shovel movie
destroyed monsters it was 150 meters or
roughly 500 feet in the next appearance
it was 300 meters or 1000 feet and that
is in final wars and lastly in
godzilla's singular point it was not as
long but still stunning at 210 meters or
688 feet in length tier 1 however has no
officially stated size but we can do a
bit of estimation i mean why not right
let's see godzilla was about 400 feet
tall but its overall length was roughly
850 feet so therefore that puts tiemout
in the range of 300 meters or 1000 feet
as she is visibly longer than the king
of the monsters now what about the
powers and abilities of these two
creatures let's start with amanda mander
can encircle an attacker or a structure
with his body and crush it similar to
how a snake could strikes its prey
binding breaker is the name given to
this constricting ability in godzilla
final wars mana can swim quite quickly
and breathe while submerged in water
despite his slowness on land man is
highly developed by your sonar organ
allowed him to fight a powerful
supersonic wave cannon and as we can see
in godzilla's single point amanda bit
godzilla on the neck causing him to
bleed which gives it a very powerful
bite force
now the powers and abilities of tiamat
tmat has the ability to manipulate water
most notably a maelstrom and a water
sprout to encircle adversaries to her
even those who are airborne tiamat's
body is coated with razor sharp scales
that can slash deep gashes into other
tyrant's skin including godzilla's
tiamat's jaws and tails can be used as
lethal weapons in battle she also
strangles her opponents like a
constrictor snake with a serpentine body
tiamat has the ability to spew a cloud
of noxious gas from her mouth that can
temporarily blind titans including
godzilla
so in conclusion although both manda and
tiamat share a lot in common such as
being water serpentine dragons having
similar constricting powers and ability
to manipulate water around them
they do have differences as well
titanostierma has hydrokinesis powers
whereas manda can shoot a wave cannon
termite can also spew a cloud of noxious
gas while manda cannot so we can clearly
say that titanic's tiamat isn't actually
manda first of all since toho didn't
lease the kaiju to the master verse but
most definitively is that tiamat doesn't
have visible limbs like manta who has
four of them well except for the one in
singular point i can say that it's
heavily based on the touhou kaiju but
tiamat is a totally different monster
from manda
and so with that we come to the end of
the video so do hit that like button for
support and click on that subscribe
button as well to be a part of the mind
cue family but most of all smash that
bell icon for regular updates on new
master videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam